so after the Great Mouse Detective we
all know the release of the Disney films
after him right Little Mermaid Beauty
and the Beast Aladdin Lion King and so
forth wrong between Little Mermaid and
Beauty and the Beast there was actually
another anime of film that everybody
seems to gloss over the rescuers down
under even today when I bring up the
rescuers down under everybody says oh
the little girl in the cave with a skull
and diamond right
no no why does everyone always remember
the bland forgettable one how ironic is
that
Ella made out of all the Disney films to
give us sequence kind of weird that they
did the rescuers but you know what they
put their damaged into this movie this
is one of the best-looking Disney
adventures that has ever come out of the
studio and I have no idea why it
continues to get the shaft alright so
what's the story we have a little boy in
Australia who of course doesn't have an
Australian accent who comes across a
giant golden eagle the last one alive he
frees him from a trap but than a poacher
played by George got captures him and
tries to force him to tell him the
location of the bird this gets attention
all the way from across the world at
least to New York where Bernard and Miss
Bianca voiced again by Bob Newhart Zsa
Zsa Gabor are requested to go down there
and save him instead of using oval the
bird from the last movie we instead this
time get Wilbur get it oval and Wilbur
it works but it works even better when
you have the comedic genius of John
Candy supplying the voice may I just say
on John page seniorita to you
may I this is just another great
passionate role that he gets into and
he's wonderful as always what miss
Bianca doesn't know is that Bernard is
trying to propose to her all throughout
the movie and yet he constantly keeps
getting distracted by this other Mouse
who's trying to put the moves on her you
really feel for this guy all he wants to
do is pop a question and some crap keeps
happening to interrupt him it's more of
a cock block than The Legend of Zelda
cartoon okay so as you can hear the
story is nothing fantastic it's just
sort of your basic everyday adventure
with little mice kind of like the first
one except it's done a million bajillion
gajillion times better like the scene
where the boy fries the eagle he could
just free her and then she just takes
him back to the net right it'd take a
minute to do but fuck that shit we get
an intense fall off a mountain
flying through the sky skating on a
river jumping off a waterfall holy fuck
just watch some of this animation
yeah this is what you're missing folks
how come nobody's looking at this on top
of that it's a good adventure it's got
some great action scenes the villain is
great hey it's George Z Scott the main
characters are likable the backgrounds
are unbelievable the animation as I said
before is spectacular it's fun it's
funny it's just a great family adventure
film there was even a short before with
Mickey Mouse called The Prince and the
pauper and you know what that's also
underrated it's a really good short
check it out I'm sure it's on DVD
somewhere so okay why is it this movie
gets so overlooked well I got two
theories one is that on the first
weekend the film did open very strong so
Disney immediately pulled all
advertising so the reason you probably
never heard of it is because you weren't
allowed to hear of it
advertising and publicity after that
what's kept very tight but I think the
other reason it doesn't do so hot is
because it doesn't have a the typical
Disney formula it's not a fairy tale
there's no song there's no strong ethics
or morals and it doesn't have any of the
extremely cute fuzzy animals that they
love to market I mean the rescuers are
cute I guess but it's no flounder but so
what
it's not supposed to be any of those
things it's just supposed to be a really
good adventure film and not only is it
good it's incredibly good do we look at
films like Raiders of the Lost Ark or
Terminator 2 as bad simply cuz they're
not as good as something like Citizen
Kane no there's still celebrated there's
still the top of their class so how come
this one doesn't get any more folks we
got to turn this around we have to
increase the DVD sales of this movie
because you know what more people
deserve to see it yeah it's a family
action flick but it's a phenomenal
family action flick taking a subject
material that really had little going
for it and turning it into a frigging
experience check it out folks you won't
regret it